Jenna is certainly an IT girl these days
and we've all come to know her signature
style it's clear that she's bringing
that style to her character in Miller's
girl what's your name Kyo sweet while
this role is different for her we can
tell from the trailers that Ortega will
be bringing her typical deadpan
sensibilities to the role of Cairo site
R Miller's girl uh beginning of October
and while this project may have sparked
a lot of controversy it's clear that it
was important to her uh just because
it's probably the most complex character
that that I've ever played so while some
may have been surprised that Ortega was
involved in such a risky role it turns
out that this is exactly the kind of
character she's most interested in
playing at the moment I always think
it's interesting to do films that make
people uncomfortable so I cared a lot
about that one